Speaker 1: We have a massive story that came
out.
The leading candidate in the GOP primary for
governor in Michigan, Ryan Kelly, was arrested
arrested for his involvement in the January
six riots.
That's.
This is insane.
Ryan Kelly, a Republican running for governor
in Michigan who was at the Capitol during
the January six attack, was arrested at his
home in Allendale, Michigan, on Thursday morning,
according to Mara Schneider, a special agent
with the FBI.
Mr. Kelly is the first person running for
election in a major state or federal race
to be charged in connection with the attack,
according to a criminal complaint.
Mr. Kelly was charged with committing violence
against a person or property on restricted
grounds, damaging federal property, disorderly
conduct and entering a restricted building
or grounds without permission.
All four charges are misdemeanors, according
to Bill Miller.
Now, Ryan Kelly is expectedly denying these
claims, but this video, I can't tell if it's
him, but allegedly it is him entering the
Capitol, waving the crowd along with him.
Let's look.
You know, he also sent out a message when
he got arrested, the judge said political
prisoner, that was a political prisoner, which
honestly, I think the right wing either never
knew or right when January 6th happened, forgot
what that actually means.
When you say political prisoner, that has
a meaning and you're not using it correctly.
Because if I posed a hypothetical to you and
I said an individual broke into a federal
building, vandalized it a bunch, fought with
the police.
Do you think they should be held criminally
responsible?
Every conservative would go, Yeah, of course.
What do you mean?
But then, because it's January six, now, any
enforcement of our laws makes it makes the
people who it's enforced on political prisoners.
That makes no sense.
Like just because you did it for political
reasons, because you believe that Trump lies,
doesn't make us the ones doing something wrong
and making you a political prisoner.
I don't know.
But obviously he should have due process.
And if he can prove that he wasn't there,
then he shouldn't be held accountable, of
course.
But all the available evidence we have now
not looking too good for him.
And funny enough, this is making an already
insane gubernatorial primary in Michigan on
the GOP side, even more wild.
If you guys remember, this was the same primary
where five candidates were disqualified from
running because they used fraudulent signatures
to get on the ballot.
Like you would think it won't get any more
bizarre than in one primary.
Five of the candidates fraudulently fraudulently
got on a ballot, but then the leading candidate
gets arrested for storming the United States
Capitol.
Like American politics is unbelievable.
And the scariest part of this is.
This could very likely make him more popular
among the Republican base in Michigan.
In any sane world.
Finding out one of the candidates in a race
for governor tried to violently overturn the
results of a free and fair election will get
you immediately banished from polite society.
But in the wacko world we live in, this can
make him a rising star.
You already know he's going to have a successful
podcast.
And with that, I'm going to do the most shameless
transition to self-promotion.
Speaking of podcasts, you can listen to my
podcast by searching Luke Beazley on any platform
or go to YouTube and search Luke Beazley.
Very nice.
We'll be back with
more
after this.